was ist los mit der oder dieses
Forschungsschiff soll herausfinden was
genau geschah bei einer der größten
Umweltkatastrophen der vergangenen Jahre
das große Fischsterben gibt der
Wissenschaft bis heute Rätsel auf im
Sommer 2022 wird der halbe Fischbestand
des artenreichen Flusses getötet
vergiftet durch die goldeige die hatte
sich plötzlich ausgebreitet weil
polnische Bergbaubetriebe stark
salzhaltiges Abwasser einleiteten zu
einer Zeit als die oder so wenig Wasser
führte wie selten
das legen ihre Recherchen von Greenpeace
Aktivisten nah die im vergangenen
wintermessungen am Oberlauf durchführten
und einen Salzgehalt feststellten höher
als der in der Ostsee
Wissenschaftler des Berliner
Leibniz-Institut für Gewässer Ökologie
bestätigen diese These
es war eine bratwasseralben Blüte und
damit eine bratwasserge im Süßwasser
blühen kann ist massiv salzeintrag nötig
und der ist natürlich anthropogen
verursacht von Menschen gemacht
jetzt erkunden die Forscher wie schnell
sich die oder von der Katastrophe erholt
an einem Morgen ist
Bundesumweltministerin Steffi Lemke mit
dabei
eine Seilwinde zieht ein Netz voller
Fischer aus dem geplagten Fluss an Bord
wird gezählt vermessen und gewogen die
Berliner Wissenschaftler staunen dass
ihnen die Zope ins Netz geht ein
karpfenfisch der in vielen Flüssen kaum
noch vorhanden ist und hier eines seiner
letzten Rückzugsgebiete hat
40 die Ergebnisse der fischzählung sind
eine Überraschung für die
Wissenschaftler
511 38 516
suche 38 5 wir hatten die schlimmsten
Befürchtungen ich bin ein bisschen
erleichtert dass ein paar Ordnung
gefunden haben die war letztes Jahr
nicht hatten es sind weniger geworden
aber es sind eigentlich von allen Arten
was wir so bisher gesehen haben die war
erwarten konnten auch noch potenzieller
da also dass ich die Bestände auch
erholen können
die oder ist nicht nur
Forschungsgegenstand sondern auch
Lebensgrundlage für Fischer wie andere
Schneider doch so schnell wird er nicht
wieder auf Fischfang gehen können
vermute mal in drei bis vier Jahren
vielleicht fünf Jahren dann wird auch
wieder mal so ein Fischbestand da sind
nehmen wir mal hatten wenn das Wasser
mitspielt die Temperatur mitspielen und
auch wieder nicht mehr solchen sowas
haben wie was was gewesen ist die Gefahr
dass ich die Katastrophe wiederholt ist
nicht gebannt davon ist auch
Umweltaktivist Norbert Bartel überzeugt
ihn besorgt dass bis heute polnische
Kohlegruben am Oberlauf Salzlauge
einleiten
wenn sich die salzeinleitung nicht
vermindert das heißt wenn man mit der
polnischen Regierung in dieser Sache
nicht reden kann was bisher leider so
ist dann bin ich nicht zuversichtlich
nicht nur Fischer Leben am und vom
Grenzfluss diesen alten Bauernhof haben
Norbert Bartel und seine Frau zu einem
naturerlebnishof umgestaltet auch in
diesem Sommer wollen die beiden ihren
Gästen Unterkunft und Bootstouren
anbieten
und können wir paddeln es kommt eine
paddelgruppe im September dann denke ich
natürlich oh im September da können sie
wieder alles tot sein und ich sage immer
den Leuten die so Anfragen kommen
trotzdem selbst wenn hier die Fische
sterben seid bei uns statt den Hof
Manuela Pieper stört der Regen heute
nicht im Gegenteil die Gärtnerin weiß
wasser ist nicht nur für Ihre Pflanzen
überlebenswichtig je mehr Wasser in die
oder fließt desto besser kann der Fluss
Salz Einleitungen verdünnen
ich denke das schwierigste daran ist
dass das überhaupt nicht absehbar ist
wie die Saison wird das hängt natürlich
alles davon ab wie sich das Leben in der
oder entwickelt unter den ersten Gästen
der Saison ist Andrea Meier sie hofft
dass die Katastrophe zum Umdenken zwingt
da wird hier was eingeleitet da was
ausgebuddelt also das was wir schon für
normal halten
hat in der Summe dazu geführt dass der
Fluss ist nicht mehr aushält und ich
habe mir so gewünscht dass es die Leute
wachrüttelt und sagt hey wir können doch
nicht den Fluss umbringen davon leben
wir doch eigentlich in Frankfurt der
größten deutschen Stadt an der Oder
erinnern sich die Einwohner gut an den
katastrophensommer auch hier sind die
Menschen besorgt na ich glaube nicht
dass die Schäden beseitigt sind und ich
habe den Eindruck die Politiker und die
Verantwortlichen dafür setzen sich nicht
an einen Tisch und klären die Sache ja
Sorge hat man natürlich immer es geht ja
nicht nur um die Menschen die da Leben
ne was wünschen Sie sich für die oder so
bleibt diese vorher weil wir sie
kennengelernt habe schon vor vielen
Jahren
am Institut für Gewässerökologie und
Binnenfischerei am Berliner Müggelsee
analysiert Christian Wolter die Daten
aus der oder den Forscher interessiert
wie sich die dezimierten Fischbestände
über den vergangenen Winter entwickelt
haben
was wir jetzt natürlich erstmal machen
ist tatsächlich eine Schadensbilanz im
ersten Jahr weil wir wissen ja nach wie
vor noch nicht wie sind die
gesamtauswirkungen wir haben ja immer
noch das Problem dass wir im letzten
Jahr vor allem sehr viele Jungfische
hinterher gefunden haben nachdem er
eigenes die unterliegen aufeinander
natürlichen wintermordalität und das
sehen wir jetzt erst was wirklich übrig
geblieben ist im Labor analysiert Jürgen
strassert unter den Mikroskop den
Auslöser des Fischsterbens die goldige
der
monokularökologe hat herausgefunden dass
nicht jede goldige giftig ist er will
die einzelnen Arten identifizieren und
untersuchen
die Idee ist die dass wir davon nicht
die gesamten Gold ein isolieren die
jetzt wahrscheinlich aus verschiedenen
Spezies oder südspezies bestehen sondern
dass wir einzelne isolieren dass wir
halt nicht irgendwie 100 haben oder 1000
sondern dass wir einen einzelnen
isolieren die Forscher wollen wissen
unter welchen Bedingungen die gold-alge
gedeiht und wann genau sie wieder
massenhaft Gift abgeben könnte sowie im
vergangenen Sommer wenn wir so ein
feuchten Sommer haben wieder jetzt der
Winter war dann haben wir garantiert
kein Problem aber wenn das das wieder in
der Trockner warmer Sommer wird die
letztes Jahr denn können die auch wieder
kommen ne wenn sie wiederkommt wollen
die Forscher schnell sein mit Hilfe von
aktuellen Messergebnissen aus dem Fluss
und Satellitenbildern Aufnahmen vom
August zeigen wie sich der hier gelb
dargestellt der goldigen Teppich plus
abwärts bewegt
wir schauen uns also regelmäßig
Luftbilder an auf dem man eine
Massenentwicklung von allen im Oberlauf
oder Mittelloch sehr schön sehen würde
dann gibt es ja automatische
Messstationen entlang der Oder also
zumindest auf dem deutschen Abschnitt
und Polen werden jetzt erst gebaut und
da sieht man auch sehr schön wenn da
viele Algen runterkommen und wenn die
allgemeine massenhaft da sind würden wir
den nächsten Schritt dann schauen ob die
auch giftig ist die Gefahr einer zweiten
Katastrophe besteht weiter und ihre
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sogar gestiegen
meint die Wissenschaft
ich befürchte dass wir jetzt einfach
schon mit sehr weniger
Salzkonzentration im Wasser
möglicherweise ähnliche Effekte haben
weil jetzt die Alge natürlich
flächendeckend im Fluss
verbreitet ist nicht nur salzhaltiges
Grubenwasser schädigt das Ökosystem am
polnischen Ufer schütten Bagger
steinladungen in den Grenzfluss mitten
in der Laichzeit so werden unter dem
Wasserspiegel alte Buhnen verstärkt sie
verengen die Fahrrinne und vertiefen den
Flusslauf offiziell dienen die Arbeiten
dem Hochwasserschutz die polnische
Aktivistin aber treffen Jack beobachtet
misstrau stehen Fortgang der Arbeiten
seit zwei Jahrzehnten ist sie im
regionalen Club der Naturforscher
engagiert sie ist überzeugt Warschau
will die oder zu einer leistungsfähigen
Wasserstraße ausbauen
ökonomisch und ökologisch ergeben diese
Arbeiten gar keinen Sinn denn die Kosten
sind enorm und die Auswirkungen auf das
Ökosystem dramatisch
die Regierung in Warschau bestreitet
nicht dass es bei den Arbeiten im Fluss
auch um Wettbewerbsfähigkeit geht
gegenüber von Frankfurt hat Polen
bereits die Buhnen verstärkt auch
deutsche umweltschützer kritisieren den
Ausbau der oder aus Sicht von Christiane
Schröder vom Naturschutzbund stellt das
Nachbarland Ökonomie vor Ökologie
dadurch wird zum Beispiel eben auch der
Wasserabfluss beschleunigt die
Fließgeschwindigkeiten erhöht damit
haben wir noch eher die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir wenig Wasser
im Sommer in der oder haben die Fischer
entlang der Oder wurden für die Ausfälle
im vergangenen Jahr vom Land Brandenburg
entschädigt Henry Schneider bereitet
auch in diesem Frühjahr wieder seine
Reusen vor probeweise war er bereits auf
Fischfang ohne großen Erfolg nicht nur
der oder Ausbau macht ihm Sorgen
ich habe viel mehr Befürchtung wenn sich
dieser Klimawandel weiterhin fortsetzt
das denn weniger Wasser in den Nebenarm
ist genau wie sie jetzt gerade stehen
und dass das dann ähm ja austrocknet was
natürlich die Kinderstube der Fische ist
Henry Schneider muss auch in diesem Jahr
empfindliche Einbußen verkraften doch
der Fischer gibt die Hoffnung nicht auf
dass die oder in Zukunft besser
geschützt und eine zweite Katastrophe
für den Fluss und die Anwohner
verhindert wird